hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the finals of the usgs championship
2021 it's fabiano corona versus wesley
so and this is only the first game of
the tiebreaks that we are going to check
out it's a three-way tie break uh
between fabiano caruana wesley so uh and
samuel savion so first it's fabi versus
wesley then it's i think wesley versus
uh
seven and then uh fabi versus seven or
could be the other way around in the
second and third match uh but we'll see
what happens so this is the first one
already completely crazy game you guys
are going to enjoy it let's check it out
uh fabi with the white pieces opens with
c4 he goes for the english opening
knight to f6 by wesley knight to c3 and
now e5 so
the the standard stuff we have knight to
f3 knight to c6 the four knights of the
english and now e4
uh grabbing more space in the center
gaining nice control of the d5 square
and uh now bishop to b4 now going for
the names of each variation now we have
d3 adding more support to the center and
black does the same we have d6 and now
a3
challenging wesley's bishop here so
bishop back to c5 and now fabi doesn't
want to take any chances and he goes for
b4 right away uh further expands his uh
pawn upon chain on the queen side
attacks the bishop and bishop back to b6
by way so we have bishop to e3 and here
wesley castle we have bishop to e2 and
now there is a game where bishop to g4
was played but here we have the
immediate bishop captures an e3 and it
is now only as of move nine that we have
a completely new game uh there is a like
i always mention more than one database
and there are some other games that
reach further positions but uh
uh i don't have access to all of them uh
so bishop captures an e3 a completely
new game with f captures on e3 now you
have double d pawns but you have the
semi-open file for your rook here on the
f file and also if uh for example
something like 97 ig6 you will have a
very nice control of the f4 square plus
you will have additional support for d4
if you'll ever need it so knight to e7
wesley goes for this knight maneuver
castles and now queen to d2 uh sorry
knight to g6 and queen to d2 fabi
connects the rooks
and now rook to e8 and uh
there are databases that say that rook
to e8 now is a completely new move but
i'm sticking with the one uh that i
usually use
so rook eight to e1 uh activating the
other rook as well and now a5 as this
rook left the a file we want to now
attack this pawn chain and then maybe
use the semi-open a file for our rook at
some point so b5 by fabi he prefers to
keep it closed and now c6 challenging
this b5 pawn we have bishop to d1
now the bishop can be shifted to c2 on
this diagonal or maybe even to b3 to
this diagonal if needed and now the rook
also has very nice control of the e file
so h6 by wesley and d4 now by fabidi for
the pawn is nicely defended so of course
he wants to
make some progress in the center with
queen to e7 wesley continues development
and the bishop the c2 now so now this
knight can move the e4 pawn is also very
nicely protected so bishop to d7 and now
fabi goes for d5 and this is um uh
something very very enjoyable as you'll
see c captures on b5 c captures on b5
and now rook e to c8 putting some
pressure along the c file as many pieces
are are here so if the queen ever moves
or if the queen is forced to move there
there could be some problem so bishop to
d3 fabi gets one of the pieces out of
the way also puts more defense to the b5
pawn and now a4 not allowing fabi to
consolidate with a for himself uh we
have queen to b2 uh preparing queen to
b4 as th this d6 pawn is a little bit
weak but also we're thinking about
bringing this knight to d2 then to c4
and then hopefully to b6 to do uh
maximum damage while the black knights
here aren't really doing all that much
there's not um
a lot of plans you can uh uh
come up with for those nights and it's
all thanks to this e3 pawn black might
at some point attack it with knight to
g4 but not as long as this rook is on e1
so queen to d8 and now queen to b4 we
have queen to a5 uh forcing a queen
trade as fabie is controlling a lot more
space this is what you want to do in
such situations and here the queen trade
is forced if you can't really move the
queen the knight would hang that's not
the correct arrow uh the knight would
hang so queen captures on a5 we have
rook captures on a5 and now rook to c1
defending our knight and getting the
rook to the only open file on the board
but now rook goes back we have rook a to
a8 and now uh knight to a2 like i said
you could also go for knight to d for
knights
knight to d tonight to c4 and then try
to go for b6 but fabi first decides to
go for this knight to a2 maneuver uh we
have knights the g4 now the rook moved
so of course the e3 phone is hanging and
here they're about down to five minutes
each i think with it was around five
minutes and 40 seconds bobby down to
five minutes
as this is a rapid game and now rook f2
e1 and now this rook defends the e e
pawn and now you might go for something
like rook captures on c1 thinking okay
white will now have to capture with the
knight but white will gladly capture
with the rook and now if you go for this
grab then we're going to play g3 now
we're going to prevent this knife from
coming into the game and now we're
threatening rook to c7 and it doesn't
matter even if you trade rooks of the
board captures captures knight to c3 now
goes after the a4 pawn uh and then you
will have to uh two
two pawns on the queen side you're gonna
push this one create a pass pawn and
hopefully win the game this way so this
would be good for white so wesley
instead goes uh king f8 you want to
improve the position of your king as we
are uh kind of in the end game knight to
b for now and here comes king to e8
again you could consider rook captures
on c1 now because the knight moved from
a2 so
it's much further away from this a4 pawn
for example rook captures rook c8 and
even if we trade captures captures now
this is uh very much different than if
the knight could just attack the the a4
pawn right away so instead uh we have a
king to e8 westley just continues
improving the position of the king and
now h3 we want to get rid of this knight
here because it's really a nuisance so
knight back to f6 and only now knight to
d2 uh we have kinked the e7 by wesley
and now fabi went into a thing here
which you know spends uh
time and the time is of the essence here
we are in a rapid game below five
minutes each uh and he decided to go for
this knight to c for movie he had to
calculate whether bishop captures and b5
was acceptable for him and it is if
black goes for bishop captures on b5
we're gonna play knight v6 put pressure
on both of the rooks and then after rook
captures rook captures now we are
controlling the the the c8 square so and
the entire c file the rook is attacked
so you'd have to move the rook somewhere
then rook to c7 check and the white has
an excellent excellent position uh so
wesley uh does not go for this bishop
captures on b5 he instead goes for rook
to cease c5 but now fabi gets this uh
amazing idea
of knight to b6 attacking the rook and
the bishop here we have rook to a5
getting the rook out of harm's way now
putting pressure on the b5 pawn uh and
now fabi has a really really awesome
move that you guys should really figure
out for yourselves uh feel free to pause
the video and try to find this
incredible move for fabi while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's knight to c6
with check or you could prepare it like
fabi did in the game with rook captures
on c5 uh it doesn't matter what order
you choose so the captures on c5 was
played in the game congratulations to
everyone who found this you are a
a true master
of uh spotting brilliances in rapid
games knight the c6 check now you have
to accept the sacrifice because
otherwise you're just losing a rook here
the rook on a5 is unguarded so b
captures and now b captures and now fabi
has this uh beautiful pass pawn here
it's ready to go to c7 to c8 and the
wesley has to figure out how to do it
you could play king to d8 and try and
stop the pawn this way but at some point
it's very likely that you will have to
give up
at least one piece for those past pawns
so here wesley does it right away uh
we have bishop captures on c6 and here
wesley was um down to some four minutes
but fabi was down to a minute and a half
so fabi really has to play fast here d
captures on c6 was played now
threatening to just win the game king to
d8 stopping c7 and now fabi has to
figure out how to continue playing this
now this is a completely superior
position for white and you have to play
something like rook to b1 uh point of it
all is that uh if uh
black plays something like knight to e7
which is really black's only active plan
to eliminate this spawn because the pawn
cannot advance the c7 you have knight to
c4 attacking the rook and once the rook
moves now you can pick up the e5 pawn
defending the c6 pawn and this is how
white uh should prevail however after
king 38 we have knight to d5 by fabi uh
thinking that okay this must be even
better because if black captures i just
improve my
position in the center but uh you know
things aren't always so black and white
in chess so here are knight captures on
the five e captures now with two
connected pass pawns but now knight's
the e7 now wesley wants to play knight
c8 and knight to d6 and create a
blockade with the knight and the knight
is a remarkable blockading piece so e4
defending the spawn and now knight the
c8 we have rook to b1 now by fabi but
now knight to d6 now saying that rook
the c8 rook to be it i really don't care
if you play rook to b8 check i'm gonna
play king to c7 and uh you know do your
thing you you can go after my pawns here
okay uh
this pawn is defended and if you go
after this pawn it's really not a
problem i'm just gonna start pushing my
pass pawn and then uh it's gonna be real
trouble
uh however after this knight the d6 move
uh fabi played king to f2 and this is
not a problem uh you could also consider
g4 because controlling the f5 square
really makes sense you do not want to
allow something like f5 but fabi started
with uh king to f2 he wants to improve
the position of his king and now we have
c4 by wesley bishop the c2 and now f5
and now you can already sense that black
is now better here king to e3 and now we
have king to c7 so now rook to b8 is no
longer even an option rook to b4 by fabi
going after the pawns here but now f
captures on e4 uh we have bishop
captures on e4 and now c3 advancing this
past pawn uh and now
it's very very dangerous you can play
rook to c5 you can capture the bishop
you can start pushing the c pawn so fabi
has to be extremely careful here and a
move like king to d3 still keeps him in
the game however he played bishop to c2
and this just
makes white's position fall apart he
blunders the d5 pawn okay doesn't blend
right he captures on a4 but now the
position is completely winning for black
and not only that here fabi had one
second on the clock and he captured on
a4 and as he was uh you know hitting the
clock before he hit the clock uh that
one second on his clock ran out and he
was in this position uh on move 46 that
fabi uh resigned the game but not uh you
know really resigned but actually he
lost on time
uh so uh brilliant brilliant game by
both of them uh brilliant by wesley for
you know just uh keeping in there and
you know surviving such an attack for
funding finding a nice counterattack for
playing faster than fabi uh and then
after all you know the dust settled
fabio was just left with a few seconds
on the clock whereas wesley had some
four minutes i think maybe three and a
half but uh all in all an excellent
excellent tiebreaker game of the us
chess championship 2021 so we'll see
what happens in the other games now
wesley still has to face samuel savion
and fog we will also face ml7 so we'll
see what happens after all three um
rounds have ended
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really a wild one a rapid
chess is always much more bloodier than
classical so hope you enjoyed that as
well
i would i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to danush and i would
like to thank jonathan to rock charles
caron uh david farney and tom darryl of
her contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
usgs championship tie breaks thank you i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day